Welcome back to the shop. Today I am finally giving you the full workshop tour.
This space took me two years to get right, and I want to show you every decision, good and bad.
We will start at the bench, move through the tool wall, and end at the finishing corner.
First, the bench. It is a split-top design with a wagon vise I built from a kit.
The top is laminated maple, flattened twice a year, and the base is mortised southern yellow pine.
Under here I keep the holdfasts and battens, because bench storage you cannot reach is not storage.
Okay, the tool wall. Everything here follows one rule: if I use it weekly, it hangs in reach.
The planes sit on a French cleat shelf, lowest angle on the left, and the saws hang nose down.
Chisels live in this rack my daughter helped me chop, which is why the spacing is a little creative.
Measuring and marking tools get the drawer, not the wall, because dust settles on anything vertical.
Now lumber storage, which is the part most of you asked about after the last shop video.
Vertical racks for boards under six feet, a cantilever rack for the long stock, and offcuts in bins by species.
The finishing corner is walled off with curtain plastic, and it has its own small air filter.
I keep oils and waxes on the metal shelf, and anything flammable lives in the fire cabinet.
Rags go in the sealed can. I know it is boring, but shop fires start in rag piles, so say it with me.
Dust control is a two-stage cyclone with a drop from the ceiling, plus the overhead filter on a timer.
The remote for the cyclone clips to my apron, which sounds silly until you count steps saved per day.
So that is the tour. The reveal shot you saw at the start took nine takes because the dog kept walking through.
If you want the bench plans, the cut list and the hardware sources are linked below, along with the rack dimensions.
Next time we are building the outfeed table that doubles as an assembly bench. Subscribe so you do not miss it.